[Music]
the algorithms that allow us to reveal
your intimate traits and psychological
profiles one of the powerful
applications of such algorithms is to
target you with marketing messages and
tailor those messages to make the most
interesting and most relevant to to you
as an individual now one of the
marketing types of marketing that is
heavily employing such approaches is
political marketing and in fact Barack
Obama was one of the first politicians
that started using algorithms of this
kind on a massive scale and now it's
kind of a fact of it it's a fact of life
that politicians will use
micro-targeting of their political
messages to reach out to the voters
naturally people are concerned about it
but my personal opinion is that people
are concerned about the wrong part of
the story here so just the sheer fact
that you can target people with relevant
messages messages that are matched to
their interests fears dreams
personalities and so on is a very good
thing that is an equivalent of a
politician coming to your household
talking with getting taking time to get
to know each one of the members of the
household and then trying to explain to
them hey you see my program this part of
my program or that part of my program
will help you to you know realize your
dreams and and prevent the best things
that you fear from happening which is an
amazing thing it keeps the message more
relevant to people it keeps people more
interested in the message and it also
makes people more competent to judge the
quality of such message which is great
for a democratic process we are having
more engaged more interested voters that
are being talked to about things that
are important and relevant to them so
just great news for democracy I believe
also it has many other you know
consequences they're very often
overlooked if I can target voters with
my message in an accurate way I
basically can stop you know broadcasting
just generic messages using TVs and you
know expensive ads and newspapers which
basically means that political dialogue
between politicians and voters became
much cheaper I can reach the voters
using way cheaper means such as Facebook
marketing targeting or adverts or tweets
and adverts or adverts and in other
environments which again has an amazing
effect of decreasing the reliance of
politicians on big-money if you can be
talking to voters at a fraction of the
cost that you needed 10 or 20 years ago
it means that you also have much less
debt to pay to big industry and and
another potentially very influential
place on the market so it's great news
and we had at least two big examples of
that happening in recent election we had
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump who both
were not the part of establishment they
both didn't have much experience in in
politics really or kind of running for
president politics and also they have
had very small funds compared with funds
that you know some other mainstream
politicians like Jeb Bush or Hillary
Clinton had and yet they were able to
energize great numbers of voters and in
the case of one of them win the election
write another I think consequence of
micro-targeting in political messaging
that people are often overlooking is
that because you are not limited to
broadcasting generic messages and you
can now micro target messages to make
them interesting and relevant to people
what happens is that now it makes sense
to reach out to the voters that were
previously excluded from the political
dialogue because maybe you know we
didn't make any
sense to try to target them with your
broadcasted message and again we can see
that with both Trump and Sanders
energizing types of electorate that was
not really energized before the larger
the fraction of the society that we
bring in to the political process the
better for democracy now having said
that you can use the very same political
message targeting to let's say this
discourage people from voting and we
have seen this in last election as well
where you could see very well targeted
messages aimed at the electorate of your
opponents to try to discourage them from
casting the vote and now this is an
awful use of such technology but again
instead of focusing on trying to you
know blame the technology for this thing
happening we should rather kind of
technology just a medium here we should
just focus on the phenomenon itself we
should perhaps start discussing whether
it's okay to allow for negative
marketing in politics and by the way
there are countries so free Western
democracies were negative target
negative marketing in politics is
basically not acceptable or even illegal
[Music]
human history is a history of great
change . we were always living through
great changes is just that recently the
speed of progress has accelerated so we
have a great change you know every
couple months or every couple yes but we
also have a lot of evidence from the
history showing that humanity basically
is just their behavior and figures out
how to avoid the downsides and employ
the upsides of a given great change you
know and you know starting from in the
agriculture through Industrial
Revolution and then something that has
more relevant to the subject of this
conversation which is explosion of
marketing you know when you had first
billboards on the roads or first large
format ads and newspapers people are
also discussing you know the arrows you
know seen as you know the end of the
world as we know it and now everyone
will be manipulated and the world we
just hand it over to marketers who'll be
just running it and you know we kind of
know that it just did not happen partly
because people developed an immune
system immunity to those ads and now I
think that the same will happen with
digital marketing you know you probably
already stopped noticing adverts on the
websites your brain learned you know
it's not worth looking at and not to
mention that now we have technology that
us blockers that just basically
explicitly remove those ads from from
your online experience
now obviously cut the progress it's a
never-ending race so once we learn how
to avoid being swayed too much by by
online ads the companies such as
developing new ways of of manipulating
or influencing us and a good example is
related to how sharing or how newsfeed
on facebook works so people don't
realize that when they see a story that
is shared by their friend the fact that
see a story is the product of both
friends sharing the story but also the
company behind the story the outlets
behind the story paying Facebook money
for this given story being shown on your
newsfeed right so people don't really
realize that people think oh it's just
my friend sharing a story and what I can
see here in my newsfeed is a
representative representation of what my
friends are talking about in fact is not
is a product of what your friends are
talking about and how much money a given
company behind the given story was
willing to pay Facebook to promote it
and I think that people don't realize it
now but with time we'll just adjust our
perception to this phenomenon as we
adjusted our perception to phenomena of
the of the past
[Music]